in this video we'll try to get a basic
understanding of
transformers a type of machine learning
model designed for processing sequences
they were introduced in the paper
attention is all you need
back in 2017 and have since gained
fairly widespread use
the original paper focused on natural
language tasks
and this is where transformers have been
most commonly used prominent examples
include
burt and gpg3 but they can be applied to
other types of data as well
such as images dolly
a transformer-based model developed
recently by openai
synthesizes images based on text
descriptions
in this example we have this silly text
prompt about a baby radish and a tutu
walking a dog
and impressively the model generates
images of exactly that
the architecture of the transformer can
be a little intimidating when you first
see it
this is the figure from the original
paper and it looks like there's quite a
bit going on
but many of these blocks are things you
may already be familiar with
like feed forward networks the key novel
components are these positional encoding
and
multi-head attention blocks which we'll
look at shortly
but before we dive into the architecture
let's take a second to understand
why the authors develop the transformer
one motivation
is that we want to limit the lengths of
paths that signals must traverse when
learning long-range dependencies
maybe our model is summarizing a long
document and the meaning of a certain
word
depends on something encountered several
sentences prior
a recurrent model like a standard rnn
that processes words sequentially
has path lengths that grow linearly in
the distance between
two positions of interest in contrast
with a transformer
path lengths will always be constant
regardless of the distance
another motivation is that for long
sequences we'd ideally like to paralyze
computation within training examples
in minibatch training we already
paralyze across examples
but memory limitations make paralyzing
within examples desirable for
extra speed speedup recurrent models
prevent this
convolutional sequence models can
alleviate this issue but still face the
issue of
distance dependent path lengths
transformers
allow for more parallelization than the
current models while also handling
long-range dependencies
they leverage what's called
self-attention to compute updated
representations
for each sequence element in parallel
the attention mechanism is going to
allow each representation
to kind of differentially consider the
representations in every other position
and the communication paths will have
the same length for all pairs of
elements
let's first walk through the encoder and
learn how each component works
the decoder will have many of the same
components with slight modifications
using language as an example domain we
start with some raw input sentence
and our vocabulary maps each word to a
unique integer
obviously these token values i'm showing
are much smaller than they would really
be
the actual vocabulary would contain tens
of thousands of words
these integer tokens are passed through
an embedding layer
a simple lookup table that pairs each
integer with a learned continuous vector
this is standard for natural language
now before we discuss positional
encodings let's understand attention
and we'll see what role positional
encodings play afterwards
the attention mechanism consists of
queries keys and values
the basic idea is that a query vector
will be compared to a set of key vectors
to determine how compatible they are
each key vector comes paired with a
value vector
the greater the compatibility of a given
key with the query
the greater influence the corresponding
value will have
on the output of the attention mechanism
all three of these components
queries keys and values are learned
during training
let's take a look at how a single head
of multi-head attention works
here we have our initial embeddings at
the beginning of the encoder one for
each word
we need to extract a key and value
vector for each one which are
implemented as linear transformations of
the embeddings
we'll also get a query vector for each
word but let's just focus on the first
word for now
we compute a dot product between the
query and each key
including the key from the same word
determining compatibility between
queries and keys in this way
is known as dot product attention
let's call this first dot product alpha
zero the next
alpha one and so on a greater dot
product indicates higher compatibility
between the given query and key
the resulting alpha vector is basically
a set of unnormalized weights
to normalize them so that they are
non-negative in sum to one
they get passed to a softmax
but just before applying the softmax the
weights are rescaled by dividing by the
dimensionality of the query and key
vectors
dk okay so why this scaling factor
well the performance of dot product
attention seems to suffer for larger
values of dk
the authors believe that this is due to
the soft max's gradient vanishing for
high magnitude input
if we suppose for example that the
elements of a query vector and key
vector
are all independent with mean 0 and
variance 1
then the variance of their dot product
is dk
dividing by the standard deviation root
dk
helps counteract this once the weights
are normalized
we use them to take a linear combination
of the value vectors
this will be the output of the attention
mechanism
we can think of it as an updated
representation for the first word
now again we don't only want to do this
for the first word we want to use this
procedure for each word's representation
in parallel let's stack these query key
and value vectors into three matrices
which we'll call
q k and v the attention operation can
now be defined efficiently
via a couple matrix multiplications
the output will be another matrix where
each row is an updated representation
for the word in the corresponding
sequence position
one neat thing is that attention is
somewhat interpretable because we can
actually
look at the learned attention weights
these might correspond to
the syntactic or semantic structure of a
sentence
now if we only use a single attention
head the linear combination of value
vectors
leads to a kind of averaging effect that
limits the resolution of the learned
representations
to alleviate this the authors propose
using multiple attention heads
that can learn different representations
simultaneously
for h attention heads we'll have h sets
of learned projection matrices
w q w k and w v
here i indexes over the heads
these matrices will project each of the
word representations
to h different query key and value
vectors
the queries and keys of course have
equal dimensionality dk
due to the dot product in practice the
value dimensionality dv
is often set to be equal to dk
the overall multi-head attention block
computes the original attention function
h times q k and v are all identical
just the stacked word representations at
a given layer
later in the decoder we'll see how q k
and v
can come from different sources the h
output matrices are concatenated and
then multiplied with another weight
matrix
w o to linearly project the learned
representations
back to the original embedding
dimensionality in the paper
the value vector dimensionality is set
to be equal to the embedding
dimensionality divided by the number of
heads
in this case w0 is a square matrix
now again unlike in a recurrent model we
see that multihead attention
does not process the input sequentially
so how will it actually condition
on the order of the words positional
encodings enable this
just as we mapped each value token to a
fixed length vector embedding
we will do the same for position tokens
one way of doing this
is simply learning them so having a
separate learnable lookup table for
position tokens
alternatively the authors also propose a
handcrafted
fixed encoding scheme essentially
each dimension follows a sinusoidal
curve
decreasing in frequency as the dimension
index i
increases here even dimensions follow a
sine curve and odd dimensions follow a
cosine
but these could be split up in any
arbitrary way
let's visualize these encodings we have
the encodings for the first 300 sequence
positions
the x-axis is the dimension index there
are 512
in total and the y-axis is the position
as we go down the y-axis we see the
encoded values alternate between light
and dark
that is high and low numerical values
but at slower rates for greater
dimensions
the authors make the case that these
hand-crafted encodings not only
represent
global position because each vector is
unique
but they're also well suited to relative
positioning
take the vector at position t then the
positional encoding at position
t plus k for some fixed offset k
can be computed as a linear function of
the encoding at position t
the authors also make the argument that
these fixed encodings can potentially
let the model extrapolate
to longer sequences during deployment
than those encountered during training
while this seems reasonable the learned
portions of the model may not be able to
do so
in any case the authors state that the
learned and fixed encoding routes led to
equivalent performance
the positional encodings have the same
dimensionality as the input embeddings
and we sum them together before feeding
them to the encoder
now multi-header tension is the first of
two sub-layers of an encoder layer
after each sublayer we apply both a
residual connection and layer
normalization
the residual connection just adds a copy
of the input to the output
so here that means the word
representations before a multihead
attention block
are added to the output representations
then layer normalization takes our word
vectors and essentially normalizes each
one
individually to have zero mean and
variance one
this was originally proposed for
recurrent neural networks as a way to
stabilize training
but helps transformers too the second
sub-layer is a position-wise
feed-forward network
this applies a simple network of two
fully connected layers with
value activation between them to each
word representation
after the second sublayer we again apply
a residual connection and layer
normalization
so we finished walking through one
encoder layer
we can stack these up n times to form
the full encoder
the end result is a fixed length vector
representation for each word
just like we started with except now
these representations consider the full
context of the sequence
unlike the original input embeddings
looking at the right side of the figure
we see the decoder
again many of the components are the
same so we'll specifically look at the
differences
just as we did for the encoder's input
we compute embeddings and positional
encodings for the decoder's input
which is the target sequence but then we
reach this masked multi-head attention
block
what does this mean well a mask is
needed to ensure that we respect the
temporal dependency of the output
sentence
that is at deployment time the output
sentence is sampled auto-aggressively
one word at a time the prediction at
position t
should only depend on the words that
were sampled prior to t
incorporating a mask during
self-attention ensures this while still
allowing parallel computation during
training
in each of the masked attention layers
during training when we update the
representation at a given position
it should pay zero attention to any of
the later sequence positions
the mask is simply an upper triangular
matrix with negative infinities above
the main diagonal
and zeros everywhere else it's added to
the result of the
query key multiplication before the
softmax
any position with a negative infinity in
the mask will result in a zero
after the softmax that is placing zero
weight on the corresponding value vector
so we understand the masked multi-head
attention block but what's this other
attention block here
well the attention blocks we've seen so
far implemented self-attention
where the queries keys and values all
came from the same sequence
for the encoder this was the source
sentence and for the decoder it's the
target sentence
this third attention block implements
what's called cross or
encoder decoder attention the vectors do
not all come from the same sequence
here the queries come from the previous
layer of the decoder
but the keys and values come from the
final output of the encoder
during deployment this allows the
decoder to attend not only to the tokens
sampled so far
but also to the input sequence this of
course is crucial if we want our output
to actually condition on the input
that is have our say french output
sentence actually correspond to some
english input just like the encoder
layers
each decoder layer applies a residual
connection and layer normalization to
each sub layer
the end result of the last decoder layer
is a vector representation for each word
in the target sequence
but what do we do with these how do we
train our model
to predict the teeth word given all the
words up to position t minus one
a final linear layer is applied to each
position mapping each vector
representation to a set of unnormalized
logics over the output vocabulary
followed by a softmax during training we
use a typical maximum likelihood
objective
adjusting the transformer's parameters
to maximize the probability
of the next step target token
in order to respect the autoregressive
dependence the teeth token is predicted
using the decoder's output at time
t minus one one quick thing to add about
the transformer architecture
is that depending on your application
you don't necessarily need
both the encoder and decoder for example
if you're only trying to generate
sequences
a decoder only architecture may be
sufficient
if you're trying to learn a rich
sequence representation for say a
classification task
maybe you'll just use the encoder
portion
towards the end of attention is all you
need there's a bit of complexity
analysis for various architectures
let's just look at self-attention versus
recurrence
n will represent the sequence length and
d the representation dimensionality
we already discussed the differences in
terms of sequential operations and path
lengths earlier in the video
but what about this complexity per layer
for self-attention the n squared times d
comes from the matrix multiplications
used in dot product attention
examining the dimensions tells us that
standard multiplication leads to
o of n squared times d operations
for basic rnn we apply weight matrices
of size d by d
with d dimensional vector
representations for the input and hidden
state
at each of n steps in the sequence
resulting in o of n
times d squared operations so which is
more expensive
well if the sequence length n is smaller
than the representation dimension d
then we don't suffer a high cost with
the transformer
this is often the case if we're only
operating on shorter sequences
like a couple sentences but for longer
inputs the quadratic cost in n can
become expensive relative to rnn's
[Music]
there's a nice connection between
transformers and graph or message
passing neural networks
we won't go into the details of gnns
here but if you've seen them before
you may realize that we can view
transformers as a kind of
gnn that treats sequences as fully
connected graphs
the transformer allows all nodes to
preferentially communicate during
message passing
according to the attention weights
there's been a ton of interesting work
on transformers in the past few years
for example on making them more
efficient developing theory on why they
actually work well
as well as some really cool applications
check out the links in the description
to learn more
thanks for watching